The problem is we have these extra--these characters,
this quote and this angled bracket--
that shouldn't be allowed in our .
Now we can check for that, and there's a couple of ways to go around this.
But the nicest way to fix this is through a method called "Escaping"--
hence, the title of this page.
HTML allows you to Escape certain characters
or change them so that when the user types in (")
we can still show the quote in the text box.
What we do is, instead of returning (") in our HTML,
we include this other string.
Instead of including a ("), we convert it to (& quot;)
and we can also Escape angled brackets.
We'll convert the closing angled bracket
into (& gt--which stands for greater than--;)
and we've got some other Escapes we can do as well.
We can convert the Less Than symbol--the opening tag--
into (& lt;)
and we conclude the ampersand--or we can Escape the ampersand itself
into "& amp;"
So if we conclude these in our HTML,
what will appear are these symbols--
but they're not actually HTML.